.
KENDRICK NUNN, THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME.
KENDRICK: THANK YOU.
CHRIS: A PATIENT POINT GUARD
WAITING FOR KENDRICK TO FINISH
BECAUSE HE IS JOINING US AND HE
IS BACK.
HE IS A TWO-TIME NBA CHAMPION.
14TH, ALLIE AND BIG GAME JAMES,
ON THE ALL-TIME ASSIST LIST.
HOW NICE IS IT, RAJON RONDO, TO
BE ONE OF THE YOUNGEST GUYS ON
THE TEAM NOW?
RAJON: THAT'S CRAZY.
[LAUGHTER]
RAJON: I WENT FROM THE
OLDEST GUY MONTHS AGO TO MIDDLE
OF THE PACK.
I AM FEELING GOOD, YOUTHFUL NOW,
AND READY TO GO.
CHRIS: I THINK YOU KNOW THIS
BECAUSE COMING OVER FROM THE
CELTICS, THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT, OH MY CUSTOMER RONDO IS
COMING OVER.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THE
CHAMPIONSHIP, THE GAME AGAINST
BOSTON, AND THEN YOU LEAVE.
WE MISSED YOU.
WE HOPE YOU MISSED US.
WHAT WAS THE BIGGEST REASON FOR
YOU COMING BACK?
RAJON: JUST WINNING A
CHAMPIONSHIP.
THE ORGANIZATION, FRANK REACHED
OUT, LEBRON, THE ENTIRE FAMILY
REACHED OUT AND SAID THEY
THOUGHT THIS WOULD BE A GOOD FIT
FOR ME AND LIKEWISE.
I DID NOTHING I WAS GOING
ANYWHERE ELSE.
I KNEW I WAS TRADED TO MEMPHIS,
BUT THE SAME TIME, I JUST MOVED
MY FAMILY OUT HERE TO L.A.
MY KIDS ARE WITH ME THIS YEAR.
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT.
IT HAS BEEN A BLESSING TO COME
BACK TO THE LAKERS ORGANIZATION
AND COMPETE FOR A CHAMPIONSHIP
AGAIN.
JAMES: YOU KNOW, RONDO, YOU HAVE
HEARD JUST ABOUT EVERY QUESTION
OVER THE MEDIA DAYS SO I DON'T
REALLY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS, BUT I
ALWAYS SAY IF THE ENTIRE
COACHING STAFF GOT KICKED OUT OF
THE GAME, IF RONDO WAS STILL --
CHRIS: YOU DO SAY THAT.
JAMES: IF RONDO WAS STILL OUT
THERE, WE WOULD BE OK.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS IN
PARTICULAR.
JUST GIVE ME YOUR SPILL ON WHERE
YOU ARE IN THE SEASON AND
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CONVEY TO
THE FANS AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING IN
PARTICULAR.
CHRIS: I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE STARTING FIVE MIGHT BE.
RAJON: I APPRECIATE THE
COMPLIMENT.
JAMES: IT IS TRUE.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT.
RAJON: IF THAT HAPPENED, I WOULD
DEFINITELY BE PREPARED AND READY
TO GO.
IT WOULD BE A SPECIAL MOMENT,
BUT OBVIOUSLY THAT IS NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN.
IT IS SUCH A GREAT TALENTED TEAM
WE HAVE A BETTER WHO IS
COACHING.
IT COULD BE ME, LEBRON, AUSTIN
REEVES.
IT IS A MATTER OF US SACRIFICING
AND PLAYING FOR EACH OTHER AND
FINDING THE OPEN MAN, SIMPLE
BASKETBALL.
ALLIE: YOU ARE ONE OF THE MOST
INTELLIGENT PLAYER IS OUR GAME
HAS EVER SEEN.
RAJON: THANK YOU.
ALLIE: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
ROSTER RIGHT NOW AS IT IS
CONSTRUCTED, WHAT HAS YOU
EXCITED IN TERMS OF THE WAY IN
WHICH YOU WILL LEAD IN THAT
LOCKER ROOM?
RAJON: JUST OUR DEPTH.
NOBODY HAS TO BURN OUT MINUTES.
NOBODY HAS TO TRY TO PACE
THEMSELVES THROUGHOUT THE
SEASON.
I THINK WE ARE A VERY TALENTED
TEAM.
AND SO MANY POSITIONS.
GUYS ARE INTERCHANGEABLE, WE CAN
CHANGE POSITIONS.
WE CAN STEP UP AND STILL
TRY TO COMPETE AT A HIGH LEVEL.
CHRIS: IS IT KIND OF CRAZY TO
THINK A CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE
BUBBLE IS LESS THAN A YEAR AGO?
OR DOES IT SEEM LIKE A
LIFETIME AGO?
RAJON: IT SEEMS LIKE IT IS 3, 4
YEARS AGO.
DOES NOT SEEM LIKE I HAPPEN GONE
FOR SO LONG, BUT IT DEFINITELY
FEELS A LONG TIME AGO.
COMING BACK THIS YEAR IN
PARTICULAR IS BIG FOR MEAT AND
UNDERSTANDING WE DEFINITELY WANT
A PARADE HERE LOS ANGELES.
CHRIS: YOU WERE PART OF THE
ROTATION AS THE OTHER PLAYMAKER.
IS THAT THE ROLE YOU SEE
YOURSELF AS, YOU CAN CREATE AND
GIVE LEBRON A CHANCE TO NOT HAVE
THE BALL IN HIS HANDS AND RUSS
THE ENTIRE TIME?
RAJON: WE HAVE SO MANY TALENTED
GUYS THAT CAN MAKE PLAYS.
I DO PRIDE MYSELF ON WHAT I DO
BEST IS PLAY MAKE, BUT WHATEVER
ROLE THIS ORGANIZATION AND TEAM
ASKS ME, WHATEVER FRANK WANTS ME
TO DO, WHETHER IT IS PLAY 40
MINUTES A NIGHT, 640 GAMES IN A
ROW AND COACH, I AM WILLING TO
DO WHAT IT TAKES.
I HAVE ONE COMMON GOAL.
YEAR 16.
NO EGO HERE.
I AM WILLING TO DO WHAT IT TAKES
TO WIN A CHAMPIONSHIP.
ALLIE: AS YOU KNOW, IT TAKES A
TEAM TO GET BACK TO THE TOP.
BUT YOU WERE ALSO PART OF A
VICTORY IN BOSTON.
NOW WITH THE ONE YOU GUYS HAVE
CONSTRUCTED HERE, WHAT IS KEY IN
YOUR MIND TO SUCCESS WHEN IT
COMES TO THAT?
RAJON: IT STARTS WITH THE BIG
THREE.
IT STARTS WITH THEM SACRIFICING,
ALLOWING EACH OTHER TO BLOSSOM.
EACH GAME WILL VARY.
THERE IS NOT ONE GO TO GUY
BECAUSE ALL THREE OF THEM ARE
THE BEST AT WHAT THEY DO.
IT STARTS WITH THEM WILLING TO
SACRIFICE AND EVERYBODY BEING
WILLING TO STEP UP TO THEIR ROLE
WHEN THEIR NUMBER IS CALLED.
CHRIS: I REMEMBER WHEN LONZO
BALL WAS IN NEW ORLEANS.
HE MENTIONED YOUR NAME AS A VET
THAT HELPED HIM.
THT UNSOLICITED SET IT ON THE
AIR.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE YOUNG
GUYS THEY HAVE AROUND YOU, THE
FEW THEY HAVE, HOW MUCH PRIDE
YOU TAKE IN THAT PART OF THE
GAME AND HELPING THOSE YOUNG
GUYS?
RAJON: A LOT OF PRIDE.
IT IS ONLY RIGHT FOR ME TO GIVE
BACK.
I HAD GREAT VETS WHEN I WAS A
YOUNG 20, 21 YEARS OLD.
I HAD KEVIN GARNETT, RAY ALLEN,
PAUL PIERCE, WHO WERE MY
MENTORS.
THEY CAME IN EVERY DAY AND
SHOWED ME HOW TO WORK.
ANY YOUNG GUY, THEY HAVE ALWAYS
KNOWN I AM WILLING TO HELP IN
ANYWAY WAY POSSIBLE, WHETHER IT
IS TO WATCH FILM, STAY AND
REBOUND FOR THOSE GUYS, WHATEVER
IT TAKES AS AN OLDER PLAYER ON
THE TEAM TO GET THOSE GUYS
COMFORTABLE AND MAKE THEM MORE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR NIGHT IN AND
NIGHT OUT PLAYING OUR GAMES IS
WHAT I AM WILLING TO DO.
ALLIE: IT IS WELL DOCUMENTED,
THE RELATIONSHIP AND RESPECT
BETWEEN YOU AND ANTHONY DAVIS
GOING BACK TO THE WHIRLING AND
OBVIOUSLY COMPETING TOGETHER FOR
THE CHAMPIONSHIP IN 2020.
WHAT HAVE YOU SEEN FROM HIM
LATELY THAT HAS YOU EXCITED
HEADING INTO THIS SEASON?
RAJON: I HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING.
[LAUGHTER]
RAJON: EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT
HOW BIG HE IS.
ALLIE: I THOUGHT THAT, TOO.
[LAUGHTER]
RAJON: I THINK HE HAS BEEN DOING
MAYBE 18 PUSH-UPS A NIGHT OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
A LITTLE BIGGER.
HE IS STILL DOMINANT A.D.
IT WILL HELP HIM IN ANYWAY
POSSIBLE GETTING ANOTHER
CHAMPIONSHIP.
EVERYONE TALKING ABOUT HOW BIG
HE IS.
CHRIS: LOOKS THE SAME TO ME.
JAMES: HERE IS A FLASHBACK.
GOT A FLASHBACK.
DENVER SERIES.
SPEAKING OF RONDO AND A.D.
RONDO GOES TO THE COACH AND
SAYS, COACH, YOU SURE YOU DON'T
WANT ME TO TAKE IT OUT?
TAKE IT OUT.
WHAT HAPPENED?
HE THREW IT TO WHO?
CHRIS: BOUNCE PASS TO A.D.
A LITTLE LOOK AWAY BOUNCE PASS.
RAJON: IT WAS CRAZY BECAUSE I
THINK I HAVE FOUR OR FIVE
TURNOVERS THAT GAME.
NO TIMEOUTS, TURNOVERS.
I HAVE BEEN ON THE SIDELINE.
LET'S DO IT, FRANK.
ALLIE: THE GREAT ONES DO.
THEY ALWAYS REMEMBER THEIR
FLAWS.
CHRIS: FIVE TURNOVERS, RHONDA.
RONDO.
BIG GAME'S DREAM IS STILL ALIVE
OF ALL THE COACHES GETTING
KICKED OUT OF THE GAME.
HE STILL WANTS IT TO HAPPEN.
JAMES: WON'T SKIP A BEAT.
RAJON: I AM READY.
ALLIE: WOULD NOT DOUBT THAT.
WE HAVE NOT TALKED TO ANYONE
ABOUT VEGAS, THE MINICAMP.
BUT WE HEARD THERE IS A NICKNAME
FOR THE YOUNG GUY, FOR AUSTIN.
CHRIS: THE ROOK.
RAJON: BESIDES WORK, THERE IS
ANOTHER NICKNAME?
ALLIE: MAN.
I HEARD THAT.
RAJON: I CAN'T GIVE YOU THAT.
HE IS JUST ROOK TO ME, BOTH OF
THEM.
CHRIS: HE CAN GET THAT
INFORMATION OUT.
ALLIE: EVERYBODY ELSE GET THAT
INFORMATION.
I TRY.
I DID.
CHRIS: CAN YOU GIVE IT TO US?
ALLIE: HILLBILLY?
RAJON: TRAVIS WAS CALLING HIM
LIGHT SKIN ALREADY, SO I DON'T
KNOW.
[LAUGHTER]
ALLIE: YOU ARE THE BEST.
CHRIS: RONDO, THANK YOU FOR
COMING BACK.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
RAJON: GLAD TO BE BACK.
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS.
SEE YOU GUYS SOON.
CHRI